so conan o'brien asked if i would be the
final guest
on his final episode of conan o'brien's
show
on tbs and i was like absolutely dude we
go back
way back what an honor is it pressure
yeah
it's a lot of pressure you think about
that the final guest that means you have
to be the best
guest of all times am i up to the task
hell yes
i aims to bring it thursday june 24th
let's be the best farewell host of all
times i'm getting nervous i gotta be
honest with you i'm getting nervous
and that's when jabil kicks it into
overdrive i gotta write some ideas
that's a hilarious idea ooh that's a
good idea as well ooh
spicy idea run that up the flagpole see
if anyone
bites oh that'll get them going
it'll get the juices flowing i'm [ __ ]
i don't have any good ideas look at what
i got this is what i got i got bullsh
all work and no play makes jack a dull
boy cancel my conan o'brien appearance
it's too much pressure i can't do the
farewell episode i got stage fright
i'm having a nervous break
check me out on conan thursday june 24th
it's gonna be lit